I've been through so much,
I've seen so much.
I've been attacked so many times.
Death threats.
I've been sexualized,
I've been threatened.
I've been so many things, and I'm still strong every single time.
Doctor Martin here.
Our society's dehumanization and adultification of black girls
has profound impacts on their mental health.
From a young age,
they're unfairly burdened with expectations,
stripping away their innocence
and exposing them to relentless scrutiny.
This not only erodes their mental resilience,
leading to anxiety,
depression, and diminished self worth,
but it also affects their performance in all areas of life,
including sports.
In the high pressure world of sports,
these young athletes face additional challenges from racism
and gender biases.
why it's so important to have licensed mental health professionals
embedded in sports.
We are dedicated to helping them develop positive coping strategies,
enhance their self esteem,
and ensure that they can focus on their passion for the game,
free from societal prejudices and mental fatigue.
We also educate coaches,
teams, and sports organizations on the importance of
inclusive environments that combat adultification,
dehumanization, and stripping these individuals of their humanity.
It's crucial to foster a sports culture that values mental well being
as much as physical prowess.
I call in everyone involved in sports to embrace sports psychology
for a healthier,
more equitable athletic community
so that players can play at their highest level
while also being champions of their mental well being.